mali says it no longer wants to be part
of a losing force five thousand soldiers
from burkina faso chad mali mauritania
and niger are in the g5 sahel it was
formed five years ago to combat armed
groups linked to isil and al-qaeda but
it's struggled to reduce attacks because
of lack of funding and disagreements
among member states mali was due to take
over as chair of the force in february
but opposition from member states
angered its military rulers
the opposition of some g5 saharan member
states to mali's presidency is linked to
two maneuvers by a state outside the
region aiming desperately to isolate
mali
mali's government accuses former
colonial power france of excluding it
once friends now foes the 5 000 french
troops deployed almost 10 years ago to
protect mali's government from attacks
are pulling out
after the military coup in 2020 leaders
of the genta hired russian mercenaries
from the wagner group for their
protection the junta is refusing to hand
over power to civilian rule for another
two years
as a result neighboring countries have
imposed sanctions on the landlocked
country sealing its borders and halting
trade prices have exploded for example
the price of soap has doubled and food
is much more expensive
basic necessities have become
unaffordable and this is because of the
embargo
if this continues we won't be able to
survive
this is unsustainable
state coffers are becoming empty with
just enough to pay civil servants for a
few months togo has offered to mediate
between mali's junta and regional
leaders while the un peacekeeping force
remains the u.n secretary general warns
of the debilitating effect while these
troubles are having on the rest of the
region threatened by armed groups
mali is increasingly isolated with
russian mercenaries remaining to deal
with a country on the brink nicholas
hawk al jazeera